so first thing I wanted to ask you was I
was reading that you had rewatched a
bunch of MCU films to prep for this one
I know Captain Marvel must help but what
is an MCU movie that folks might not
expect to have influenced this movie
heavily o um Iron Man 3 how so um I just
love it so much for of all I think it's
just I think it's one of the best uh
Marvel films um but also in a really
practical sense actually the um the uh
what's it called the
um oh my gosh I can't believe I'm
forgetting this you have a lot your mind
I know like oh my God my brain um what's
the thing called the thing that was
under their skin the fiery thing the
extremis extremis thank you oh my
goodness so the extremis effect which I
really loved in the film was um
influenced us on another thing we did in
our film which you'll see when you watch
it okay fair enough fair enough look
forward to that so one thing I wanted to
ask you about from our press notes is
you said when you sign on for a Marvel
movie the first thing they tell you is
to talk to other directors two questions
about that who gave you the best advice
but then also having gone through this
experience what advice would you give a
future MCU director based on how it was
making the marbles wow um it's so hard
to say the best advice
because like you just need different
things at different times I would say
the best oh but they were also all great
okay the person I talk okay the person I
talked to the most was Dustin keton um
and he was just great at like knowing
every s of the process like oh yeah
you're stressed about that but you don't
have to be stressed about that oh at
that though you know was like very like
I've been through this I get you um and
then um Ryan couler is really great like
I've said this a lot like you know be
yourself and that's probably what I
would say to the next person like just
bring everything you have um they can
take it or leave it but like as long as
you bring everything that you have and
that's for everyone actors the
department heads you know you've done
done everything you could going back to
what Destin said what is one thing that
you should be stressed about when making
a Marvel movie but then what is one
thing that most filmmakers would be
stressed about but you actually should
then okay um that you should be stressed
about
um I mean for me in this movie we had a
lot of cats and I was going to be
stressed about I was like oh my God what
are we going to do but actually it was
fine so there something I didn't need to
be stressed about um something that you
do need to be stressed
about I don't know you kind of have such
a great crew that like at the end of the
day like when you figure out how to
collaborate and work together no problem
really
is too big surrounding yourself with the
right people makes all the difference on
any film and also having the best
possible cast that's where I want to go
next I love talking about the different
approaches to acting out there so can
you maybe name something specific about
Briana andiman in terms of how they
approach the work maybe even something
about them that calls for something
different from you as their actor's
director for sure yeah um so I think
everyone needs something different in
order to get to where they want to get
to and there were a lot of there's so
many levels to the performances for all
of them in the movie um something that
Bri Bri says a lot is like what are the
stakes you know you know she wants to be
sure that she's understanding exactly
how I'm how I'm envisioning the end
result of the scene in terms of the
emotional tenor of it and so that was
something that I thought was really
helpful and really cool and specific to
her you know like what are the stakes
and and being clear about that was
really helpful to her um and then Tiana
like was so specific and visual so it's
like we're on a blue screen stage she's
like what is it what does it look like
you like wanting all that detail so that
for her like she can like internalize
that um and then Aman and I would just
geek out and set but she's also just
like Aman's like the most the most
prepared like knows all her lines knows
everything um and um I don't know I
specific to Mom Bes I just us just like
nerding out but uh but yeah it makes all
the sense in the world every interview
that I've watched with her like that's
the vibe I get from her and I love it I
want to jump to uh the talend of the
process now specifically when it comes
to test screenings cuz that part of the
process fascinates me because I find it
can be so to figure out when to take
notes and when to pass on them so can
you maybe give us an example of each a
time when you got a note you took it
applied it it made the movie better but
then another note you got where you're
like you know like this doesn't feel
right for my movie and I'm not going to
do that um I mean that's sort of every
film making process where whether it's
getting notes from your Executives or
you do cuz even if you're not doing test
gettings in the way that Marvel does you
can do you know like I I usually like to
just get like a group of people I trust
and have great taste together and that's
really um that's really helpful for me I
think I can't think of anything specific
because it literally is you get every
kind of note you could possibly think
about like you get literally someone
said I don't like that tank top what am
I going to do about that literally
nothing so um so I think it's really
like and I think about this when I give
notes am I giving a note because I'm
asking them or wanting them to do it the
way I would have done it or or am I
giving a note that is improving what
they actually wanted to do and so those
are the two kinds of notes that you get
usually like I think the ones that you
take are the ones that improve the movie
that you're trying to make and the ones
that you leave behind are the ones that
make a movie that the way someone else
would oh God I hope everyone who attends
a test screening listens to that and
understands that mentality and approach
to it I'm so excited to see this movie
congratulations thank you so
much